boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Stalin Saki on
very excited to be talking about global
politics in 2019 everything from deep
fakes to autonomous lethal weaponry to
all different types of exponential
technology and peace or bust we got to
figure this out and that's why we're
doing a show on it we're gonna break
down a bunch of these points and as well
as the nuance around them so let's jump
into it so I got a bunch of notes to
share with you all as we go so we got to
start off with exponential technology
and what this means as we move into the
2019 era of global politics so there's a
ton of insanity that we're facing with
this as you know the law of accelerating
returns is impacting every single
industry and there's a big huge insanity
happening and it's been happening now
with deep fakes so there's already tons
of work being done on deep fakes we can
see people from around the world that
weren't actually saying what they were
saying but being portrayed saying it
it's being used in a ton of different
malevolent situations and I'm actually
going to go ahead and walk us through
some of the terrifying possibilities
that exist here fake videos could
feature public officials taking bribes
uttering racial epithets or engaging in
adultery politicians and other
government officials could appear in
locations where they were not saying or
doing horrific things that they did not
fake videos could place them in meetings
with spies or criminals launched in
public outrage criminal investigations
are both soldiers could be shown
murdering innocent civilians and warzone
precipitating waves of violence and even
strategic harms to war effort a deep
fake might falsely depict a white police
officer shooting in on our black man
while shouting racial epithets a fake
audio clip might reveal criminal
behavior by Canada on the eve of an
election a fake video my poor train is
really official doing something or
saying something inflammatory as to
cause riots and they bring countries
potentially disrupting diplomatic ties
or even motivating a wave of violence
false audio might convincingly depict US
officials privately admitting a plan to
commit this or that outrage over
exquisitely time to disrupt an important
diplomatic initiative a fake video may
depict emergency officials announcing an
impeding missile strike on Los Angeles
an emergent pandemic in New York
provoking panic or worse we gotta
remember look at all these scenarios
this is not solve these scenarios fake
videos fake audio fake adultery fake
diplomacy fake rioting causing rioting
through deep fakes when you can't
distinguish ibly tell the difference
between what's real and what's fake our
whole entire internet propaganda and
cyber war efforts we really need to do
to Kate as much malevolence as possible
as soon as possible so we can really
grow from a heart centric place from a
unity place and we got to be teaching
children this otherwise we are gonna
have some serious issues then this also
includes things like people putting with
their faces in tub into porn videos
where they're not actually there and
putting those on the Internet
this includes all different types of
behaviors like this and this is nuts and
this is this could stir up crazy riots
around the world and and just catalyze
some crazy
oh that's fake that's a deep fake this
is a deep fake well how we're gonna know
truth this is a huge leap pressing issue
that we got to really think about
solutions to and there's interesting
technologies in place like we got to
really see what we can do with
encryption technology who have
blockchain technologies to show proof
proof and Trust and we have to grow from
the heart as well that's the best
solution to not have any of this
malevolence as soon as possible so deep
fakes are are just nuts okay as well as
of course this one which is crazy
autonomous war drones and robots we've
all now seen Boston Dynamics robots
doing backflips we've seen it just
imagine you know an assault rifle with
that Boston Dynamics robot imagine the
Sault rifle and then imagine computer
vision software just parsing and looking
at people finding the ones that are
malevolent you looking at
would be diffusion analysis to tell
where they're at what they're doing what
their psychometric states are and their
biological states etc it's is nuts and
this is also part you know part of that
is seeing this type of site you know
autonomous weapons org highly recommend
coming here to their proposal to ban
lethal autonomous weapons this is so
crucial you can share the video I'm
gonna show you a little piece of the
video called slaughter bots on YouTube
here right now so you know look at this
this drone he's tossing this drone out
he's pitching this drone the drone has
this facial recognition software and
boom it just goes right into the into
the head of the targeting kills them
just like that look at how easy it is
for us to just completely kill bee we
can drop tens of thousands of these into
areas where there's malevolent people
etc well how about we grow better from
the heart so that we don't have to have
these types of issues but this is really
important though that we're highlighting
this because we really have to grow
together as a civilization and support a
ban on lethal autonomous weapons support
heart centric thinking teach kids about
this because this is a serious foresight
this is not fear-mongering this is
foresight this is very similar to doing
things like saying that oh my gosh too
many people are are dying from fire we
need have fire extinguishers where too
many people are dying from automobile
accidents we need to have seatbelts and
automobiles we need to have traffic
lights right this is very similar right
we need to grow we need to learn there's
a there's a threshold we're learning
from mistakes is no longer wise we can't
have mistakes with things like these
autonomous lethal robots and drones we
have to be very careful as we approach
this exponential technology age and
efforts like the future of life
Institute are doing a really good job
here I'm gonna pull them up here in a
moment and I'm gonna share that with you
because that's part of the autonomous
war drones and robots and as as we get
there because that's more on the
handling nukes and AGI as well side
there's a huge push happening with cyber
war right now and and we have we have we
have close friends that are working in
teaching and disseminating how crazy did
you
political IP theft seen as cyber war
seen is internet propaganda seen is and
we highly recommend going and checking
them out as well that is go to invent IP
dot-com inv and t IP comm and then when
you go to general info regarding IP
conflict you can see at this top bar you
can see these latest articles that they
have and these latest articles are nuts
I mean look at this US charges hackers
traders with stealing SEC filings Huawei
unveils cutting-edge Big Data chip as
China pushes in 2018 Trump tightrope
trade walk war of worlds between Mike
Pence Xi Jinping China calls from
multilateralism free trade system with
EU NSA leader creates task force to
fight Russian cyberattacks so going and
just looking here at these latest
articles can give you such an edge in
understanding the sheer complexity of
what's happening in cyber war and a
sheer and the sheer complexity of what's
happening geopolitically to be awakened
and to be enlightened to some of the
true malevolence that actually occurs
and realizing that fully that it can't
that it's not just tomorrow we can flick
on peace love and understanding because
some people have malevolent efforts
they've grown up in areas that have put
that have in the US has some of these
areas too that has that has caused
people to be more manemma level and due
to their environmental stimuli x' and
whatnot so it's up to us to really pass
along this this trajectory of overtime
becoming more hard centric and working
on ourselves and teaching kids this and
having geopolitical flourishing but
right now there's it's insanity on on a
crazy geopolitical level with cyber war
on one on so we have to really figure
out how to come up with solutions to all
these issues and these need to be at the
front and center of a majority of what
we are doing in order for us to best be
able to flourish okay I'm gonna show you
a bit on the future of life Institute as
well a future life Institute is really
important as well they have the 23
assimil Rai principles are very
interesting and important to go check
out they're working on you know
artificial intelligence safety and
security research as well as I'm Dean
clear is a ssin so there's you know over
10,000 of these nuclear weapons still on
the planet and we had almost two
instances of mutually assured
destruction in the Cold War that were
just barely prevented by Vasily arcing
pavan stanislav petrov thank goodness
that they did that and there's a bunch
of ways that we can Dinu clear eyes and
work with AI safety and security and and
and really come up with the right
solutions that we need here and and
preventing things like bio warfare
neural warfare and that's a lot of what
some of these podcast some of these
articles some of these grants that
future of life Institute is working on
highly recommend checking them out as
well okay so that's a bunch of that's a
bunch of general idea on what we're
facing with the sheer complexity
geopolitically of exponential technology
and this is the first and foremost
crucial point that we have to remember
as we move forward and be teaching other
young people about this around the world
and having more conversations about it
okay moving on to point number two point
number two no more monkey politics all
right
this is super important we are this is
no longer this sort of greedy corrupt
selfish sort of incumbent systems aren't
gonna work anymore there are really
strong principles of democracy that we
need to take and we need to upgrade some
of the code to democracy 2.0 to
capitalism 2.0 to maximizing the
flourishing of all people 2.0 we have to
figure out how to do that and we have to
have more scientists engineers designers
artists critical thinkers involved in
updating our democracy that the need for
the sword of heart centric unity
thinking humans is so crucial to be in
these roles of leadership scientists and
engineers and entrepreneurs are in many
ways at the forefront of the cutting
edge of knowledge and they need to work
with politicians as well and governments
to be able to deal with these pressing
issues building trust across borders is
so crucial we've seen I'm gonna get into
that in the next portion we'll get there
and eradicating these parasitic
behaviors
we got to work on building out
meditative practices psychedelic
practices what we need to realize really
truly how to best move forward
collectively and this is you know this
is a really good example of like what
like have you guys seen this before this
is the Venus Project Venus Project is a
very interesting project there they're
like why is civilization not shaped like
this and it's a great question because I
I know so little about what exactly is
possible with civilization that what is
going on here in this image are we
talking like some sort of of proto Pia
like slowly a slow incremental progress
to a very prompt regressive state of
flourishing because I don't know how do
people live there what do they have
access to are there you know robots an
AI doing a lot of things how do how do
you how do people have some sort of a
incentivized in a style of innovation
etcetera but it looks gorgeous and it
looks completely sustainable and you
know an eco driven and eco friendly and
and and still highly innovative and
technological and whatnot so these are
like why civilization and the metropolis
is shaped the way that it is and why do
we still have so much dirt and grime and
garbage and in many position many people
that are positioned in in ways that they
don't want to be positioned in extremely
poor poverty disease ridden statuses
that want better opportunities how can
we fix these issues Venus Project is
like yo check this out we can we can
have a different style of civilization
so this is really important to keep in
mind that we are not locked into where
we're at that we have a lot of space to
grow and envision these types of
civilizations and go and try these out
and in funding towards them to build
these out and to explore them into but
there's a huge push into metropolis so
you have to network effect like people
have to be moving there by the droves of
high influence to get more people move
there it's some very crazy like
macroeconomic and network theory things
that actually go into that okay and this
as well so many people
no Rutger is very interesting he was
just historian he was just at Davos and
when he was there he basically said that
why is it that these three thousand-plus
extremely wealthy global leaders are
having all these panels but only one or
two of them are actually on wealth
inequality because there's been a severe
concentration of wealth and we're all
very aware of this but the solutions
aren't obvious and but one of the things
he says is yo like stop talking about
philanthropy and start talking about tax
evasion because but hold on a second
even though that is an interesting idea
which it is of course is actually paying
your fair share of taxes on the
extraction on the extractive economy
that's actually going on and when you're
doing that and you're extracting wealth
from people of lower and middle SES you
become more and more responsible to not
just fuel that money into a fifth yacht
or a fifth house but you become
responsible to do things like innovate
yourself if you're not gonna pay taxes
if you're gonna choose to not give the
government the ability to do things like
somehow incentivize further innovation
through their programs and whatnot that
you need to incentivize the innovation
and so this is where the balance between
extreme taxation like extremely high
marginal tax rates 70 80 90 percent
versus if you're going to go pursue you
donating the giving pledge if you're
gonna give 90 percent of your wealth
away as a billionaire then you got to do
it right away in the most effective ways
possible hiring thousands of people to
tackle some of society's biggest
challenges and things like that how do
we further propagate that sort of a
mentality and how do we figure out
what's the best between high marginal
taxes and giving governments of letting
them distribute it or having these
extreme like think tanks and innovation
tanks through things like The Giving
Pledge be really resourceful because we
would much rather see the most
beneficial possible options so that's um
make sure that this money is being
wisely spent is a huge huge key here
people need dignity they need something
to wake up every morning passionate
about so
again a lot of people are throwing
around these these extremely like
kindergarten ideologies of like you know
universal basic income great there's a
nuance here we can explore things like
this but you have to realize that
somehow people still need to find
meaning and dignity in their life every
single day when they wake up we have to
realize that and figure out what is the
best way to test these hypotheses and go
out and and and do the ones that make
the most sense that are actually being
tested in the best ways and again this
is highly nuanced to figure this out but
no more monkey politics putting the
right scientists and think-tanks
together to actually develop further
plans for geopolitical flourishing is so
crucial in 2019 all right on we go this
is gonna be extremely crazy this section
is nuts I'm finding out the truth
because here we are we find ourselves
after a long period of evolution as
stewards of Earth and as we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth after
this long period of evolution we have
North America we have South America we
have Africa we have the Middle East we
have Europe we have Asia and we have
Indonesia and we have Australia and then
no one lives in haruka so this is just
very an interesting blue marble an
interesting blue and green marble and we
have no idea how to how to be effective
at flourishing yet we are we have
discovered electricity and Internet and
food and water ubiquity and these things
are good and they work but we need them
and more done more effectively and we
have to have a global discourse about
how to do this better because right now
we're lacking that global discourse
isn't it nuts that we have this platform
these major video distribution platforms
and and social media distribution
platforms yet why are they not
sponsoring themselves the most
thought-provoking debates geopolitical
debate series out there why don't we
have a world cup of ideas
where were a man and a woman from every
single country around the world
participate in debates around how to
maximize human potential why are these
not happening these need to be happening
and they it's deer can be sponsored by
these largest technology companies
around the world in the US and in China
especially with so much money and so
many users using their platforms so we
challenge you the biggest technology
companies pursue things like this
because we are we're gonna do it and you
are - with us we're gonna all do this
together oh man look at this thing so
now there's so many different countries
what do these countries want how do we
figure out the truth what does the
United States want United States gained
its independence and now we find
ourselves after 1776 we find ourselves
with the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights and all these great things and we
have this code that needs to still be
updated but what is the United States
going to do what does the United States
truly want massive military budget
massive GDP and what is it trying to do
around the world the same exact question
can be asked of China China's number two
now in the world in GDP and China's
making a tremendous amount of like
intellectual advancements and what does
China want the China's doing the belt
road initiative China the China's belt
road initiative is pushing all across
the eastern hemisphere and are they
trying to you know help with the
flourishing of the economies over there
or are they simultaneously trying to
give deals to these countries that are
completely in China's favor at the same
time and is that the best way to do
business
some countries say yeah come on in some
countries say no no no these a horrible
deal so you know what is going on there
with China in the eastern hemisphere
what's going on with the United States
and the Western Hemisphere
the United States becoming more energy
independent now with shale oil and not
needing necessarily to be relying on the
Middle East reserves of oil you know
what is that gonna be doing why are
there these nationalistic efforts now in
the United States and in with with the
United Kingdom leaving with brexit what
is going on why are these things
happening can there be more nuance can
we figure out how to have more of a
global mentality while simultaneously
also realizing that we need to increase
the amount of trust and we need to be
able to handle things
like these exponential technologies at
the same time how do we properly move
forward how do we have this global
geopolitical discourse in 2019 all right
so again what do these different places
in the world truly want what does Russia
want what does a Middle East want what
does Africa want was your up one and
what exactly has been happening in the
United States side of things what has
been going on in the last three years
this has been freaking crazy
why is manna for cohen flynn and so many
others why are they pleading guilty and
some of them are going to jail isn't
this all frickin crazy Comey being fired
Clinton's private email server DNC email
hacking Mueller Special Counsel
investigation dozens of indictments and
still roaring Trump's personal
organization what's going on there with
the nuance of him being present and him
also having a massive conglomerate
across the world of resorts and hotels
and all this other kind of stuff you
know really truly what how has this been
happening for three years and what is
the actual truth why have we not found
the truth yet in the most we're now
three years this is crazy that all these
things are happening in the you in the
United States and exponential technology
is making this stuff even crazier with
deep fakes and internet propagandists
and cyber warfare we have to really be
careful moving forward and we have to
really be truthful art centric we gotta
do this this way alright let's move on
to the to the next section you know we
were talking a bit about what's going on
with Frances social issues what's going
on with German and Italian economies how
about Switzerland and the rest what are
you would the rest of the rules of
European countries what do they want
what is Japan South Korea North Korea
want the Middle East in many ways is
building the future but social equality
is behind in many ways Africa coming up
unleashing their creativity but there's
a major land grab going on at the same
time like the old Scramble for Africa
this is secretly happening right now
with land for Africa competing to who's
gonna provide these next 1 billion
Africans that are being born into the
world because their population pyramids
are all super low they're super trying
to
the youth is about to to blow up and
who's gonna be providing them with their
basic needs what's going on in Venezuela
what is going on with indigenous people
around the world like the Native
Americans in the US what did the u.s. do
like why are why are we not more
attentive to what's happening with the
Native American population and who's
taking care of them who's taking care of
the indigenous populations in the
Amazonian area because that's similar
thing people are trying to live there
peacefully but economies are pushing in
and affecting them as well and why are
we pushing into people's lives that are
trying to live peacefully on the land
and don't even get me started on the
Rohan Jian genocide and the Rohan Jian
displacement that's happening whatever
is going on there is in crazy look not
only at this these shanty towns and
refugee camps that have been set up that
are being crazy but look at this look
it's stuff like this there's moms and
they're holding their daughters that are
starving and that have been fled from
their homes same thing with fathers and
brothers here you know again just barely
getting the necessary nutrients that
they need that are this is this is
absolutely crazy and it's so difficult
to actually find the truth again we want
to find the truth what happened in
Myanmar with the Rohan Jian people
they're militants and fighting back this
way that way what is the truth and how
can we stop these types of insane crisis
from occurring around the world where
two million of them have been displaced
now over a period of several years this
is in sane and we can't we can no longer
be so ignorant and not find the truth in
these matters and it's also crazy
because this is the cycle of news and
we're gonna we're gonna touch on this in
a moment it's just moving so dang fast
that we're not actually able to keep up
with the cycle here let's let's let's
let's let's jump let's jump into that so
the in this section this is Occam's
razor verse conspiracies I think this is
a very interesting section for too
global politics because Occam's razor
says simpler solutions are likely to be
correct than the complex ones very true
very true very true it's much more easy
to think that and it's very true not
only is a cognitive easing and it's and
it's also it's also just it's also just
you know true we've tested that the
molecular composition water is a certain
way and you know we're so so so certain
of that on a part probability
distribution so likely that is correct
now and it's not likely that there's
some massive global conspiracy around
the molecular composition of water right
ok but how about things like because our
new new cycle is moving so fast and we
talked about the several times not only
with the row handguns and what's going
on there but also with things like the
2016 election in the united states also
things like that's only three years old
and we are still in 2019 again trying to
figure out what actually happened there
holy crap we still haven't gotten to the
truth after three years what about
things like 9/11 what about programs
like MKULTRA what about all the other
insane conspiracies that have been
happening over the last couple of
decades that we haven't actually gotten
to the truth about why are we still here
today after 15 25 35 years after these
incidents and we don't have the truth
yet we have to be more we have to be
better at identifying the 1% we have to
maximize the success of people that have
this Copernicus mindset this Galilean
mindset this idea that we know that the
earth is not the center of the universe
there's just orbits around the star that
we need more hubris
we need more hubris this has happened
over and over and over again in
civilization and the more humility that
we have the we the hubris is extremely
overwhelming it's it's the hubris runs
rampantly we're overly self-confident
we're not humble enough we need to be
more humble and as we stay more humble
and we can uplift the 1% thinkers again
be very careful with this we mentioned
this here the 1% thinkers can also be
very dangerous at times because the 1%
thinkers like again if someone's trying
to argue the molecular composition of
water if some
trying to argue gravity's not 9.8 m/s^2
pulley now if someone trying to argue
that we have to be really careful
because you know the probability that
they're right is now very wrong is very
low so we have to be careful with that
what is true but at the same time
there's people that are arguing 1%
mindsets of things like potentially the
2016 election or 9/11 or I'm Kaila are
everywhere Higgins what's going on row
hanger what's going on between Palestine
Israel what's going on between Armenia
and Azerbaijan what's going on in China
and what's going on between North and
South Korea what's going on in all these
different places in the world where this
is all happening how do we get to these
unknowns faster and get them written in
the history books correctly now is more
crucial than ever so we have to do that
we have to figure out how to uplift the
1% and test these hypotheses best is
there's a good way to put it all right
and on to the last one very simple slow
down and think breathe and be grateful
for life be grateful that we're all born
here on earth and we've had this just
absolute pleasure of being able to be
birthed into all this ubiquity and so
much but there's so much pressure on us
to to be able to figure out how seven
point eight billion of us can work
together in this exponential technology
age slowing down and thinking so
important that this whole notion of we
have to race we have to race for the
first to have artificial general
intelligence for the first to have the
best genetic engineering technologies
the first to have all this transhumanism
technology we're having ethically
matured out of kindergarten yet we have
to mature out of kindergarten develop
our hearts develop our meditation or
unity senses build trust across borders
deal with these ethical quandaries that
we have in exponential technologies an
autonomous weapon and slow down and
think breathe be grateful this is ours
this is sacred we got this
in increasing the baseline of freedom
the economic degrees of freedom around
the world
to unleash the fullest creativity of as
many people as possible so crucial
alright let's do a quick review of all
of our points everyone again global
politics in 2019 is absolutely crazy and
we're approaching the exponential
technology age we have to be very
careful with deep fakes autonomous war
drones and robots again what are we to
do about all of the cyber war the IP
theft the psychometric profiling
internet propagandists talk to people
around you have these conversations how
are we gonna handle the nukes the AGI
how can we wrap people's minds around
these complex geopolitical scenarios and
get them more have them give them more
time to go and research these things and
explore these things and again go and
check out the links to the x stack the X
Tech learn about deep fakes learn about
banning lethal autonomous weapons
autonomous weapons org future of life
Institute future of life org and then
invent IP inv and t IP comm go and look
at these everyone go and start talking
about these more often
ok exponential technology how are you
deal with that no more monkey politics
having more heart centricity having more
scientists designers and engineers
updating democracy 2.0 capitalism 2.0
spirituality 2.0 let's get there
together have the billionaires and the
wealthy class be the ones to develop
their hearts out while though we'll meet
them together in the middle that from
the lowest will of SES will push up and
from the top we'll have them help push
everyone up as well but we have to
develop our hearts we have to get there
together and people need dignity they
need something to be passionate about no
more monkey politics it's time for that
advanced spiritual politics finding out
the truth the sheer complexity of all of
the countries around the world and what
do these countries want how can these
countries work together especially being
the bridge between the United States and
China which is something that I care
about so much I want to be the huge
bridge between the US and China would be
a huge bridge between Hollywood and
Silicon Valley we need to disseminate
really powerful unity media between
these countries
in between these areas in California as
well and really understand some of the
complexity and the deepest scale about
what's going on across these different
countries in the world and how to
prevent more of these refugee crises
that were seen Occam's razor and
conspiracies figure out how to help that
1% with the right hypothesis testing to
see if they're actually right and how
can we get to these truths the fastest
slow down think breathe be grateful and
increase the baseline for everyone in
2019 I love you all thank you so much
for tuning in this has been this has
been such an honor and such a pleasure
to be able to to work with you guys
again look at look at this this is this
is crazy beautiful we have the potential
to be able to get to this point and even
more we have the potential to become an
interplanetary species we have the
potential to eradicate as much suffering
as possible and maximize the degrees of
freedom for as many people on the planet
as possible we have the resources on
earth to be able to do this they're just
not distributed well enough yet and we
also have to develop our hearts to
practices like meditation and
mindfulness and psychedelic use we can
do this together it's up to us let's do
it together everyone really think about
this pressing state of the geopolitical
concerns that we're facing in 2019
because it is gonna be a crazy year and
again it's up to us to have these
conversations have these conversations
with your friends have them with your
families have them with your co-workers
have them with people in your
communities at the deepest levels
possible teach them to your kids teach
your kids and people around you to be
more vigilant about the way that they
consume media because of the deep fake
era and remember all these tough
conversations have them understand our
global political sphere better and get
ready for 2019 buckle up critically
think and let's have more nuanced
political discourse and share that
around the world and think globally act
locally and go make change let's do it
let's build the future together I love
you all so much thank you so much for
tuning give us your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear for
you join the community on simulation
we'd love to to start building out this
global community and making these
actionable steps all the links are below
to that support the local entrepreneurs
and artists that you believe in the
scientists that you believe in everyone
go and support them support them that's
so so crucial for their development and
growth support simulation as well if you
believe in us all that info is below
helping us scale and one not again build
the future everyone we love you so much
manifest your destiny into the world we
will see you soon keep having these
nuanced discourses and thinking globally
and geopolitically we love you so much
and we will see you soon again I'm your
host Don Sathyan you can find cool stuff
like this who will teach robots ethics
sure simulation series comm you guys
know where to find it and keep up making
cool things like this and
thought-provoking conversations around
the world love you so much and we'll
talk to you soon